[Music]
[Music]
today as we honor and as we learn from
Kofi Annan we take great pride in the
small role that we played in his
education and in shaping his early
career but we also bear witness to the
importance of maintaining the openness
of our universities to foreign students
scholars and faculty we must guard even
in these complicated times and protect
this fundamental American and academic
value and principle it is my privilege
and honor once again to welcome to MIT
the secretary-general of the United
Nations
His Excellency Kofi Annan
thank you then
thank you very much my dear friends
president vest let me thank you for
those very warm and kind words of
introduction Indian Amnon Zee I'm really
happy that I'm back here with all of you
as Sloan distinguished faculty members
and students and dear friends it is
indeed a pleasure for me to be back here
and to join you today for this
anniversary celebration over the course
of half a century Sloan School of
Management has built itself into one of
the world's academic powerhouses I say
world and not just country because right
from the beginning
Sloan looked well beyond the confines of
this campus encourage people from many
nations as we heard from the President
to study here and was eager to find and
advance the course of international
cooperation scholarly and otherwise
congratulations on this milestone three
decades ago I was fortunate myself to
become part of the Sloan community and
it is good to see so many familiar faces
since I've been down here yesterday and
and an event like this really brings
back memories of when I first came here
what the place was like and where I
myself was at in the state at that stage
of my life I recall in particular the
slowness posed me to some very
interesting work in organizational
culture and psychology and how to manage
change that may sound like jargon to
most of you but I can assure you that it
came in very handy at the United Nations
and I leading
back in 1982 when I was working with a
High Commissioner for Refugees in Geneva
and were trying to grapple with the
crisis of the board people I invited my
good friend and professor Cheyne to come
to Geneva to help us improve our
internal communication and to review our
mission when we gathered everybody came
we thought we're going to have a
straightforward discussion for one hour
three hours later we were all physically
and emotionally drained from what had
quickly turned out and to be a frank
soul-searching exercise for all of us
what it meant to be working for the
United Nations what were we trying to do
with the refugee crisis of the time and
how best to get different people and
people from nationalities around the
world to work better together some
frustrations had been bottled up
obviously for years but once the
floodgates were open we found new ways
forward and a truly new sense of unity
and purpose image the session was so
successful that I organized another one
in 1990 we're at shine and professor
Lester Thurow came to talk to the group
we gathered about 30 senior officials
from 26 different countries to discuss
similar issues and they all walked away
very enthusiastic I like to think that
we are replicating that exercise on a
global level among peoples and nations
as we strive to build the trust
confidence and the sense of shared
values and responsibility needed to
address the urgent issues and threats of
our time we are all aware that more and
more challenges from environmental
degradation to drug trafficking and the
spread of diseases such as hiv/aids have
a global diamond
through work travel and trips to the
store we can all see that trade and
communications are stitching human
family ever more closely together these
phenomena are also helped have also
helped to make the 21st century a very
troubling times for our global village
distrust between cultures and religion
often leads to violence and has been
aggravated by the terrorist attacks of
9/11 concern is mounting because of
global economic uncertainty and because
the benefits of globalization have been
shared so unevenly confidence in Marcus
has been dealt a feather blow with a
series of corporate scandals in the
United States and the gathering feeling
that Marcus by themselves cannot respond
to the real needs of society or provide
the Bob publicans that humankind needs
to survive in an age of interdependence
global citizenship is a crucial pillar
of progress in a series of global
meetings and conferences over the past
two years in particular world leaders
have tried to define what that
citizenship means they have been trying
to build an inclusive responsive
effective international system which all
people can bend from which all people
can benefit from and in which all feel
they have a stake shared responsibility
was at the heart of the declaration
adopted at the Millennium summit in
September 2000 160 heads of state and
government gathered in New York all
countries came together not just to
express their general hopes for peace
and development in the 21st century but
also to give their back they are back
into a set of various
time-bound objectives which have since
become known as the Millennium
Development Goals the goals include
reducing hunger provide an access to
safe drinking water and ensuring
universal primary education they will be
closely monitored and measured how many
kiss I in school how quickly hunger and
extreme poverty are being reduced and we
will advertise the resource in such a
way that we hope will galvanize politics
and policymaking so that the goals can
be met by the target date of 2015
governments face a first first test of
their commitment to these goals last
November at the World Trade Organization
meeting in Doha their trust was the main
issue on the table trust because the
development countries have had a lot of
talk about free and fair trade but seen
too little far too little of it they
want to know that they approach their
products will have an equal chance to
compete in the global market that
chances that chance is currently denied
them because of tariffs on their goods
and because of subsidies given to their
competitors in the rich countries
subsidies that I might add also
perpetuate unsustainable practices in
farming transport and energy use the new
round of negotiations agree to adorn her
office the prospects that Marcus will
truly be open but it is only a promise
and it is too soon to say whether that
trust in the trading system will be
achieved only time will tell but I think
we need to work hard and press ahead to
open the markets
truly for all countries
next came the Monterey conference on
financing for development last March
that conference was also an exercise in
recognizing shared responsibilities the
conference generated substantial new
pledges for official development
assistance reversing a decade-long
decline and made good progress on issues
such as debt relief investment and
corruption just as as important
developed and development countries
reached a common understanding on their
respective responsibilities in the
pursuit of balanced and equitable
development and finally last month our
the World Summit on sustainable
development in Johannesburg global
citizenship once again took center stage
all leaders committed themselves to a
path of development and economic growth
that saved gas resources and ecosystems
for succeeding generations leaders from
rich countries in particular agreed to
reduce their nation's ecological
footprint on the planet taken together
these summits and conferences give us a
blueprint a blueprint for development
that puts people not States not GDP
statistics at the center of policymaking
the overriding challenge now is
implementation and for that we shall
need people from all sectors the public
sector private sector civil society to
forge more and better partnerships to
implement these schemes one of the most
welcomed developments are the United
Nations in recent years has been the
steadily growing engagement of the
business community both in policy forums
and in projects on the ground though the
relationship is not without its
difficulties there is growing
recognition that we must move beyond
politics of confrontation and the
solutions to poverty environmental
degradation and other challenges can
only be found if the private sector is
involved and is an effective partner
more and more businesses themselves are
coming to recognize how they depend on
international norms and standards for
the conduct of business on a global
scale and that the United Nations
wide-ranging work in peace and
development has an impact on how they do
in 1999 at the World Economic Forum in
Davos I introduced the idea of a Global
Compact the Global Compact was based on
my belief that Marcus and human
wellbeing can go hand in hand over the
long run human wellbeing can be
dramatically advanced by
well-functioning Marcus but Marcus
themselves cannot be sustained if they
do not ensure human well-being as I
asked businesses at that time to embrace
nine universal principles in the areas
of Human Rights core labor standards and
the environment and to enact these
principles within their sphere of
influence and make it part of the way of
doing business I picked these ideas
because I was worried by a severe
imbalance in global rulemaking while
there are extensive and enforceable
rules for economic priorities such as
intellectual property rights there are
few strong measures for equally vital
concerns such as human rights and the
environment
the compact has since become more than a
call to action today it involves not
only businesses but also labor
Federation's and non-governmental
organizations it has promoted the
importance of unity
values and encourage investors to look
harder at opportunities in the least
developed countries particularly in
Africa the compact has created the Lenin
forum a worldwide economy academic
network that examines case studies
trying to determine what works and what
doesn't and I'm pleased that Sloan plays
an important role in this forum none of
this is meant to is meant as a
substitute for action by governments or
as a regulatory framework or code of
conduct rather the compact is a
voluntary initiative a platform for
showing how markets can be made to serve
the needs of society as a whole business
may ask why they should go down the spot
especially if it involves taking steps
that the competition might not or steps
they feel are rightly the province of
governments sometimes doing what is
right for example a Curie efficiency or
creating decent decent workplace
conditions is in the immediate interest
of business sometimes we must do what is
right simply because not to do so would
be wrong and sometimes we do what is
right to help usher in a new day of new
reforms and new behaviors we do not want
business to do anything different from
the UH normal business we want business
to do their business differently we want
them to continue what they do but bear
in mind these values that touch all of
us dear friends openness is the Imagine
hallmark of our time but we need to make
it work otherwise countries and peoples
might
retreat behind protectionism or worst of
all reject global citizenship or
globalization in favor of narrow
concepts of national interest not at all
appropriate for this interdependent
world we live in for this global village
business is well-placed not only to
generate employment investment and
growth but also to advance the global
citizenship Sloane is well-placed to
teach more than economics accountant and
finance and to help define the
parameters of corporate citizenship and
I am delighted to hear that your program
is already evolving in that direction
and there's a great deal of enthusiasm
for the program on corporate citizenship
and the United Nations is well-placed to
promote dialogue that were build trust
and create the multilateral norms and
frameworks needed to fulfill our shared
responsibilities all of us the private
sector civil society labor unions NGOs
universities and foundations and
individuals like you must come together
in an alliance for progress together we
can and must move from value to values
from shareholders to stakeholders and
from balance sheets to balanced
development together we can and must
face the dangers ahead and bring
solutions Within Reach
thank you very much and congratulations
on this to the Sloan community on this
important day I will now be happy to
take your questions
[Applause]
Thank You mr. secretary-general
I have a number of questions from the
audience and perhaps more will be
forthcoming but let me let me pose one
for you do you see a link between
corporate responsibility and corporate
citizenship on the one hand and the gulf
between haves and have-nots on the other
do companies have a positive role to
play in creating a sustainable future I
think from what I have said this morning
it is clear that I see a very important
role for the corporate world and I think
corporations that respond and react to
these norms do make a difference in the
communities and the societies in which
they operate corporations and the
leaders of corporations are often very
important personalities in their own
communities and can influence policy and
decision making by governments and help
steer laws in the right direction but
they also make a difference in the
day-to-day lives of the of the
individual corporations don't have to
wait for governments to pass laws for
them to know that their productions
should not pollute the water that
produces fish for the village they need
to they need not wait for governments to
pay a decent wage they need not wait for
governments to try and train their
people and give them a take the question
of hiv/aids corporations have done
fantastic things around the world
Volkswagen do Brasil for years watched
is good managers contract the disease
and die off and they took the decision
we are going to do something about this
came up with a program of education and
treatment for their managers and the arc
families and then begin to see these
creative men and women live on continue
to deliver today
and passing the message on to their
families and communities how to protect
yourself so the role of corporations in
issue of development and their society
is extremely important and some are
doing extremely well now at edge or this
to look at what works and what doesn't
and corporations do have a role thank
you another question from the audience
is what can we at MIT at Sloan and those
of us assembled do in particular to help
realize or advance the Global Compact
initiative
I think you've you're already on the
right track by training your students
and discussing the Global Compact
initiative with them and I'm sure you
also have a chance to advise many
corporations and you would be able to
expose them to this and talk to them
about it I've I've had a chance of
meeting some of the Sloan fellows in New
York and I've been struck by how
enthusiastic they are and I know that if
a quite a few of your professors are
also working on the Global Compact and
so I think apart from IDI teaching it
here but the learning forum and what we
are going to put on the web to share
with others becomes an important way of
spreading the word the other thing that
we are doing is a learning forums that
we've introduced where for example
corporations can come together to
discuss what their responsibilities are
and what their posture should be if they
find themselves operating in areas of
conflict
what is suspected of corporations whom
should they tend to for advice and how
did they work together to cope and all
this I think is going to be extremely
helpful for corporations and I'm
extremely happy that US corporations are
beginning to join the compact we've had
tremendous response from Europe from
Latin America Asia and elsewhere in
Africa recently Hewitt pocket has joined
FISA is coming on board and I expect
many more will
what responsibilities do American
corporations in particular have in the
global community
you see us you see a special
responsibility because of well I think
today it is it is it is business and
these corporations that have become the
main motor for creative for the creation
of wealth they have technology they have
money and they have management and they
also have a global rich in some ways a
corporation's understood faster and
better than governments that we do live
in a global world and they work across
borders and they also know that in doing
that you need to have some rules and I
think the corporations that operate
around the world should see their role
not only I say New York headquartered or
Silicon Valley headquartered but they
should try and also lift the people in
the countries in which they are
operating and also help the societies by
passing on some of the knowledge and
some of the technology and the training
where they fail to do this they
inadvertently become part of the
conflict or the problem we've seen as
can give you an example look at what is
happening in Nigeria with Shell BP Shell
where the villages around the oil
production sites feel they have seen
nothing of the benefits that accrue from
exploitation of the oil the money goes
to the central government the probe the
shareholders take their profits and they
see nothing and continue to live in
squalor I think it was two or three
months ago when a group of women
demonstrated and took over one of the
side now shell has indicated it is going
to help them and is going to put some
money back and in fact even if it is not
direct responsibility of shell in a way
could have pressure the government said
don't you think we should be doing
something for the villages around here
can we pull together and do something
these kinds of gestures go a long way
and I know some companies have done it
an average or they said to do that not
only train the local people pass on
technology but ensure that we spread the
benefits a little bit more I have a one
word question which I think we'd all be
pleased if you would address briefly and
that question is Iraq I thought I was
going to get away with not a perfect
screen yeah no Iraq obviously is a very
topical issue is a very difficult issue
for all of us and the UN has been
involved with this problem for over 12
years now and the inspectors as you know
we're we're drawn from Iraq in December
98 and since then we've not had
inspectors back in Iraq earlier this
year I got a letter from the Secretary
General of the Arab League saying the
Iraqis would want to sit with you to
discuss the return of inspectors without
conditions so we arranged to meet and
that was I think in February or March we
we met three times as here the last
meeting was in Vienna we seem to be
inching forward but no real breakthrough
or progress and then the General
Assembly met on the 12th of September
and at that time the US government had
become very focused on the Iraqi issue I
I spoke and President Bush spoke we both
demanded Iraq to comply in my statement
I made it
several points but the two I would want
to share with you argue in that any
country when attacked has an inherent
right of self-defense under article 51
of the UN Charter but when the country
decides to deal with a broader threat to
international peace and security the
approval and support of the Security
Council is required that we need to have
that basic understanding otherwise we
will face major difficulties down the
line so we were all delighted when
President Bush spoke and informed the
world that he's going to refer the Iraqi
issue to the United Nations I also
indicated to the council that in such
situations they will also have to have
the will and live up to their
responsibilities the Security Council
you know what has happened in the
Congress and so I'm not going to come
and comment on that but in the Security
Council there is a debate going on now
as to the second stances under which the
inspector should be sent back there is a
sense that the disarmament regime will
need to be strengthened the inspectors
would need to be strengthened so that we
don't repeat the errors of the past and
that they could go in and they can go in
with a strengthened hand and get their
work done my sense is that that
resolution will be passed there so lots
of discussions and negotiations going on
and I expect the council to send in the
inspectors with their strengthened
regime with a demand that Iran should
perform and with the request that the
inspector should report back should Iraq
fail to do so and if Iraq wait have
failed to do so
I suspect the council will indicate the
consequences that Iraq will have to face
up to there has been a suggestion that
maybe in even in this resolution they
should be the phrase if Iraq fails all
necessary means must be used which is a
code word for me
three could phrase for military action
when I think the member-states wanted to
stage approach sending the inspectors if
they get into trouble if it fails come
back and we'll pass the second
resolution so this is where we are and I
expect that by within the next week or
two the council would have acted the
chief inspector Hans Blix and his team
are ready to go they met with the Iraqis
and discussed the practical aspects of
resumption of their work but they are
waiting for the council to act so that
if there are new instructions they can
factor it into their work and of course
all the Member States will work together
and my plea to the council is that they
should work in unity from experience it
is only when the council is united that
they have the greatest impact and I hope
and trust that the council will be able
to manage this process in the way that
we keep the unity of their member states
together we keep the USA in the fold
working with the Security Council not
just for today but for tomorrow and the
day after thank you very much
Thank You mr. secretary
you